69 departamentos en francia ahora son
denominados como zonas rojas se han
dividido en tres niveles de alerta con
diferentes medidas y restricciones la
zona en alerta más baja es una donde el
coronavirus se está propagando
activamente las zonas de alerta
reforzada incluidas parís lyon y burdeos
están viendo como el virus se propaga
más rápidamente especialmente entre los
ancianos la situación sanitaria se
considera extremadamente grave en las
zonas de máxima alerta donde los
servicios de salud están sometidos a una
presión cada vez mayor como es el caso
de la región de marsella y el territorio
de ultramar de guadalupe si la situación
sanitaria empeora en dichas zonas se las
pondría en estado de emergencia se
tienen en cuenta varios factores
diferenciales al definir el nivel de
alerta de una zona roja comenzando con
el número de contagios por cada 100.000
personas durante una semana que está por
encima de 50 para zonas en alerta más de
150 para zonas en la alerta reforzada y
más de 250 en aquellos de alerta máxima
también se considera el número de casos
en personas mayores de 65 años así como
el número de ingresos en unidades de
cuidados intensivos